look we we we don't know
what's ultimately going to play out here
i'd be stunned if trevor lawrence
ends up going back to clemson remember
that was suggested at some point and
we're going to get to that in a second
but whether you go back to clemson
whether you enter the draft now
you still unless you're going to pull
the john elway or eli manning power play
and there's risk involved in that
because it could blow up in your face
unless you're going to do that you're
always going to get picked if you're a
great player
by one of the worst teams in the nfl
that's just how it goes chris
yeah it is that's how it goes there's no
doubt but i mean
i think that that interview was very
telling you know i i think in a lot of
ways one
the confidence in which he talked about
the next phase of his life basically
like it's it's of course a foregone
conclusion which which it should be you
gotta leave clemson
you know you gotta you gotta get you
know you know what do they say
you strike why the iron's hot or get
going when you know
you can either way i mean it's it's
there you don't you can't pass up that
opportunity and take a chance of getting
hurt
and you know i think we're seeing with
that guy too just trevor lawrence and
how he answered that
i think he welcomes the challenge i do
you know as we saw with joe burrow and
the bangles last year
and everything that that way you know a
lot of the times
these type of quarterbacks they feel
like
hey i can come in there and change
everything about this organization
and change not only the way we're
perceived you know off the field but the
way we look on the field
and i think a lot of young quarterbacks
or quarterbacks in general
kind of relish those opportunities you
realize like oh
it could get dicey because i might not
have a lot of support around me
but the reward is so great that i think
it really
you know makes quarterbacks or big time
players you know
relish those situations more times than
not his comments did create the
impression that he's definitely leaving
clemson so dan
followed up hey so it sounds like you're
definitely not coming back here's what
trevor lawrence had to say to that
officially leaving clemson right after
the final four
i mean it's it's likely obviously i'm
not i don't want to completely shut any
door
but uh well didn't they introduce you on
senior day so that i thought that might
have been
their way of saying that yeah so i'm
graduating so
coach sweeney let me go ahead hey but
christian wilkins he he did it twice he
ran down the hill twice
two years in a row so you never know
i never heard of somebody having two
senior days but uh what the heck if they
let you do it you may as well do it
the way he's smiling he's not he's not
right back why would you go back
no look
going back to clemson should never be
the issue don't go back and play for
free don't get exploited any more than
you've already been exploited by a
system that makes billions
and does not pay you fairly and does not
even let you
earn fairly based upon the the fame that
that you are
are earning through your abilities and
sacrifices etc
if you don't like the team and you don't
want to play for the team that has the
first pick then
then make your power play make it behind
the scenes let someone else make it on
your behalf like eli manning did
but it's amazing to me the power plays
work
they're 2-0 they're undefeated we just
never see them chris
you're right well it's it's not normally
in the the dna of a quarterback or a
football player to do those type of
things
you know i think that's that's that's
really you know it's rare
john elway was in a situation he didn't
like eli manning had his reasons you
know as far as the manning family and
what they didn't like about the chargers
but more times than not you know these
top alpha
big time football players they welcome
this kind of opportunity
you know and and you know i just hey you
look at this the top of the draft is
going to be very interesting i mean
you know who who's going to be up there
you know jets jacksonville we know that
who are the good teams going to be after
that that you know maybe in this
quarterback conversation that maybe even
would make a play to trade with the jets
to get to the number one pick
i think that could be uh i think you
should always consider you should
always consider that offer because you
get more
lottery tickets in return
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports